I am not inside a fusion reactor. It'd be
wonderful if I was,
the Joint European Torus reactor here at Culham
Centre for Fusion Energy
is behind some blast doors just a few metres
away,
but that's not really somewhere humans are
meant to go.
Not even for maintenance: it's not really
dangerous
in the same way that current nuclear power
plants are,
but it contains toxic beryllium and low-level
radioactive... stuff.
This is the mockup version of the reactor,
used for training. And by the way,
if the camerawork here seems a little bit
odd,
that's because it's being done by... well,
here.
Meet my camera operator.
Say hi!
I was going to say that my camera operator
is a robot,
but that's not strictly true either. This
isn't a robot,
it can't carry out anything automatically:
instead, it's a remote handling arm. Basically,
it's an extension of John over in the control
room.
It's not as versatile as a human arm,
but it's got enough degrees of freedom.
You are actually there, at that point,
and not detached from it in a control room.
You don't even realise you're doing it.
You're actually thinking about the job as
you're there,
and you're imagining all the components around
you.
Certainly from the views, we have a VR model
as well,
which gives us good detail, so from that you
actually work at the coalface
imagining that the items are there right next
to you.
It's got very good feedback. Even down to
something as thick as a layer of tape.
If you were to put that on a smooth surface
and run the grip across it
you'd be able to feel that level of detail.
We have to service the ceiling as well,
so the transporter will drive the manipulator
upside down and up into position
so the operator stays in this position, but
gravity changes.
So we have to teach the operators to deal
with that as well.
There are all sorts of cool technologies for
remote presence
that could be used one day.
Virtual reality. Gesture recognition. 3D cameras.
All of which would be great: if they work
reliably, every time,
and if they'll still work and be supported
after
10, 20 or 30 years of use in a radioactive
environment.
This system can't be experimental, it can't
be risky,
because the only way to fix or upgrade this
robot arm inside a reactor
is to send in a human.
You don't take risks for something like this:
you use something that is known to work safely.
And I did ask whether I could have a go controlling
the remote handling arm.
For all those same reasons, the answer was
yes... but very, very slowly.
[Translating these subtitles? Add your name here!]